It speaks not only of a place but a plan planned
to be enacted in the event of morocco's defeat
are his successor welcome back everyone is charlie
this will be my full lord of the rings rings of
power episode 3 video there were a whole bunch of
easter eggs so we'll break it all down if you're
brand new to the channel i will be doing videos
for all the episodes be sure to subscribe to
get them careful for spoilers from the episode
if you haven't seen it yet we'll just start at
the beginning and work our way through shot by
shot talking about easter eggs and wtf moments
starting with the title the title was adar he's
the fallen elf character played by joseph mawle
who most of you remember as benjen from game of
thrones the way they're using him on the show
they've explained is that he's sort of like the
mid boss on the way to sauron eventually so he's
not meant to be another form of sauron he's like a
completely separate character they created for the
show he's not somebody from the books because of
galadriel's prologue at the beginning of episode 1
talking about how things never are evil in the
beginning i think he was also one of the elf
children that were there in the prologue you
see a very fuzzy version of his face teased at
the end of the episode the actual episode felt
like it was more about setting up numenor and
setting up the place that will become mordor
in the southlands here and confirming the mark
of sauron is also meant to be a map of what mordor
will eventually become the whole reason why sauron
decided to make mordor here make his realm here
is because the natural mountain range provided
this natural protection just making it easier for
him to defend the area during the episode when
arandir looks up around at all the devastation
that the orcs have wreaked on the area that is
foreshadowing the devastation that sauron's forces
will wreak in this area so that eventually it will
look more like this as you see it during the
events of the lord of the rings movies a lot
of people also been calling this southland's area
before door because it will eventually turn into
mordor which i think is kind of funny before door
the other real big reveal too is what's going on
with hal brand's character and now i actually kind
of think that he might turn out to be the witch
king of angmar or it might wind up happening
is theo might turn out to actually be his son
and he might wind up becoming the witch king later
in the timeline i already explained how hal brand
is connected to the southlands like the sigil that
he wore around his neck was the same sigil that
we saw in the southlands and galadriel also finds
the documents in their hall of records the ancient
records that reveal that's the mark of royalty
in that area previously the same kings that
swore fealty to morgoth during the first stage so
the kind of setting up hal brand is the reluctant
leader kind of like aragorn during the events of
the lord of the rings movies where at first he
doesn't want to have anything to do with it he's
very reticent because he's worried about falling
to darkness the same way that his ancestors did
the same way that aragorn is kind of worried about
falling to darkness the same way that a silder
who we also meet during the episode his ancestor
fell to the influence of the one ring so i think
in this episode they soft confirmed that hal
brand is not going to be a version of sauron and
also adar is not meant to be a version of sauron
either there's a couple of characters that wonder
if that's the case because he is an elf but he's
meant to be a fallen elf completely different
character than sauron so we probably have not
seen sauron yet i think the whole idea is they're
setting up adar here to be the boss of season one
and then towards the end of season one then maybe
they'll reveal what's going on with sauron and up
to that point we'll just see his mark all over
the place and his influence be felt but the
episode begins with the orcs capturing iran deer
and taking him back to their camp where we find
out they're holding everyone captive forcing the
men to work in their tunnels making them bigger
basically slowly turning the area into what
will eventually become mordor with all this
devastation you can see their path just extending
for miles all the other elves that he meets in
here are the same elves that were working at
the tower who have also been captured since then
then we check back in with galadriel and hal brand
who wake up on the numenorian ship on the way back
to numenor confirming that it's allendyl's ship
he's isildur's father who recognizes her as one
of the eldar the eldar is the ancient name that
the valar gave to the elves just in general so
even though there are many groups of elves all
over different parts of the world they're all
referred to as eldar it'd be like calling all
the people on earth humans of earth the reason
he uses this term at the beginning is because they
want to set up his connection to the elves in the
valar in general i'll talk about this throughout
the episode as they reference some of these things
but there are a lot of references to the faithful
and a lot of the things that happen in the books
but obviously you can see they've compressed the
timeline because the isildur that we remember
is actually during the war the last alliance the
one who cuts the one ring off of sauron's hand and
in the books that's like thousands of years later
but numenoreans only live for about 200 years
so there's like this massive time compression
during the second age so it's a little bit harder
to follow if you're going by book events so we'll
just have to see what stuff they all throw into
the pot here that winds up being the actual show
but the other big connection between his family
and the elves are through elrond's character so
numenor was founded by elron's twin brother elrose
when they sail in here the giant statue that's
looking out over the bay is a statue of elrond's
twin brother elrose they were both born half elven
and they were given the choice to either live
life as an elf and they would gain immortality
like the rest of the elves or they would live
life as a human and they would live normal human
lifespan elrond chose to live life as an elf
and thus he continues to live for thousands of
years but his brother elros chose to live life
as a human married an unnamed woman we don't know
who his wife was in the books and they founded the
nation of numenor the statue in the prison area
here might be of elrose's wife or his mother in
elrond's mother l wing and as they explain the
island of numenor is kind of like an atlantis
in the world of tolkien but the island itself and
this longer lifespan was given to them as a gift
by the valor because of their service during
the war of wrath in the first stage like the
valar literally rose the island out of the water
and they just gave it to him say hey this land
belongs to you now and we're also doubling your
lifespan so like a normal member of their race
might live for about 200 years aragorn for example
is one of the last descendants of a sealed dirt in
his father orlando that's why he's about 210 years
old when he dies because he has numenorean blood
in his veins he was also about 87 years old during
the events of return of the king so obviously it
looks very good for his age during this part of
the timeline in the world of tolkien a normal
human lifespan like the southlanders is more like
90 years when galadriel refers to numenor as the
land of the star that's because their island was
brought up by the sea by umo as a gift to the dane
for their part in the war against morgoth it was
also called star wards because the dane were led
to it by the star of arundel and because the
island was in the shape of a high-pointed star
you actually see the five-pointed star symbol on a
lot of their weapons and armor too when they sail
in it looks fantastic love the special effects on
this obviously spend a bunch of time and a bunch
of money on this part but if the architecture
looks familiar that's because most of the major
structures like the castles the towers in middle
earth later in the timeline during the events of
the lord of the rings movies are all built by the
numenoreans after they came to middle earth or the
ones that survived the doom and new manure for
example gondor founded by a sealed door in his
family after they came to newman or obviously one
of the major events in the show they're building
towards is the creation of the rings of power but
the other major thing is the downfall of numenor
sauron was also mostly responsible for the
downfall of their race by tricking them
into invading valinor like i said though a lot
of the events of that in the creation of the
rings of power are like two completely different
parts of the timeline but i think that they've
compressed that because they're compressing the
timeline for the show itself so we'll see how
long it is before they actually forge the rings
of power or they start forging the rings of power
and how soon we actually see the downfall of
numenor that might wind up being like the very
last season of the show when both of those things
happen like they might just have those happen
in the same season it sounds like the way that
sauron is going to trick the elves like the
promises he's going to offer them in creation of
the rings will be similar to the promises that
he offers to the numenoreans that will lead them
to try and invade valinor to their great doom i
didn't get too much into this in my episode 1 and
episode 2 video but the whole idea is that keller
brimbore says that he wants to create something
that will last and that's why they need to create
the world's greatest forge basically the whole
idea is that during this period the elves actually
want to find a way to preserve their realms so
that they'll be everlasting in the way that their
own lives are everlasting because even though they
continue living like they're functionally immortal
all the life around them like the cities
that they live in the land that they live on
those things decay like you would normally expect
and the elves want to find a way to make it be
a little bit more like it is back on valinor so
the whole idea is that sauron is able to trick the
elves into creating the rings of power because one
of the effects of the rings is to preserve life so
that's probably what he's going to tell them like
look i found a way we can preserve everything but
we have to create these special rings in the
whole idea with the downfall of numenor because
even though they have longer lifespans they kind
of set this up during the episode this hatred that
they have for the elves and for the valar when
they're talking about the previous king being
deposed because he actually liked elves and he was
trying to take them back to more pro-valar stance
what basically happened is that over time over
the centuries the numenoreans eventually grew to
regret not having the same immortality as
elves and started to resent them for that
so sauron basically lets himself be captured
by the numenoreans and eventually tricks them
into worshiping morgoth thinking that if they do
they will gain immortality by invading valinor
there are a couple references to this later
in the episode and a group of numenoreans
that they call the faithful like they literally
mention the word the faithful during the episode
i'll explain a little bit more about that in
a second we'll get to that part of the episode
during the first episode though when galadriel
almost sails back to valinor and this big veil
seemingly opens up this very magical looking
veil and you hear this song in the background
it feels like for the show they've actually kind
of moved things around in the timeline and they've
sort of upgraded what they call the ban of the
valar on valinor like they basically ban everyone
from sailing to valinor so like if you had a
ship during a certain part of the timeline you
could still try to sail there now you'd probably
get killed if you came with inside of it but you
could still do it after the downfall of numenor
literally a louvitar basically cracks the earth
and changes its shape to around like the earth
used to be flat before the downfall of numenor and
separates the entire continent of valinor from the
rest of the world so the only way to reach it is
through magic so even if you did have a ship after
the downfall of numenor you couldn't just sail to
valinor if you wanted to your ship would just get
lost in the sea here everyone probably recognizes
the white tree similar to the white tree of gondor
the white tree of gondor was basically taken from
seedlings from this particular white tree the
whole thing with the white trees is that they're
like the same species of tree as the original
two trees that were destroyed by morgoth in
the giant spider angolian the only difference
is they don't give off the same light that the
original two trees did but they are the same type
of trees the really cool ability that these trees
have though is that the white trees will shed
their petals when they sense the evil is afoot
during the trailer you see the white tree of
numenor shed its petals i think that's the
whole idea that sauron has started walking around
the earth in the tree is sensing that evil later
in the episode when a lendil is at the hall of
records with galadriel and says that it was barely
survived from being destroyed by the previous king
one of the things that sauron tries to do once
he eventually twists the numenoreans towards the
side of morgoth is to cut down the white tree the
reason why there's a white tree in gondor later in
the timeline though is because a sealeder is able
to steal some of the fruit from the tree and they
use the seeds from that to plant a new white tree
also later in the timeline after aragorn formally
becomes the king of gondor and unites the realms
of men he also finds another sapling of the white
tree and plants a new white tree during most of
the events of the movies their white tree has
already died then we meet pharazon and his
wife tarmurial the current queen region pharazon
is important because he's the person who
basically presides over the numenoreans trying to
invade valinor he's like the person responsible
directly for the downfall of numenor even though
sauron tricked them into doing it muriel is the
right-born daughter of the previous king pharazon
kind of usurps her power when she's forced to
marry him so you get this whole xenophobic vibe
going on in numenor it just gets worse and worse
and worse until they eventually try to invade
valinor they say muriel's father is trapped in the
tower sort of like an exile within numenor just
forced to live out the rest of his days there his
name was tar palantir which will remind you of the
palantirs which we actually saw in the trailers
those are the seeing stones that you see later
during the events of the movies they were created
by feyenoor who also created the silmarils which
they mentioned in episode 1 and episode 2. there's
all these scenes with hal brand having this silver
tongue trying to talk his way into staying on
numenor but it's all i think a misdirect because
he's kind of this reluctant king type figure
kind of like aragorn like he gives galadriel's
dagger back and they become a little bit closer
previously he was like number one on my sauron
watch list like it just seemed so deceiving here
but now i think it's actually more likely that he
winds up either becoming the witch king of angmar
or one of the nine kings of men that become
ring race one of the advantages that the show
has in doing the origin of the witch king in
the nazical is that there isn't a whole lot
about their backstory that the books get into
so it's sort of like a wide open area like in
the books they never reveal who the witch king
of angmar was before he became the witch king
also he has a flaming sword that looks a lot like
the flaming sword that theo was using in episode
2. when they mention allendale's son we see
isildur for the first time famous eventual king of
gondor who cut the one ring off of sauron's hand
like i said after his father was killed and then
fell to the one ring's influence the thing you
have to remember and they kind of mentioned this
later in the episode is that he has a brother
named anarion and then many generations later
you have aragorn one of the major additions that
they did on the show though is that they gave them
a sister so a silder has a sister on the show but
not in the books we'll see if she becomes a big
part of the plot like i don't know why they would
include her on the show if she wasn't in the books
if she wasn't going to be a big character on
the show isildur hears a very ethereal woman
whispering his name from a distant island you
can let me know in the comments what you think
that is a reference to i couldn't find any direct
references but i think it's all meant to tie in
with the idea that a silders family elendio's
family is part of the faithful and that's one
of the reasons why they're able to survive the
downfall of numenor because like right after
this you hear muriel talking literally mentioning
the word faithful the faithful are basically the
people amongst the numenoreans race that still are
loyal to the valor the ones who were not tricked
by sauron into worshipping morgoth so later in the
timeline they're the ones that leave to colonize
middle earth and eventually build gondor and a lot
of the other major structures that you see during
the events of the war of the ring alandel explains
the origins and the meaning of his name it means
elf friend in quenya the language of the elves is
because his family the area that they come from
on numenor are still faithful to the valar even
though the way they explain it in this episode
largely the numenoreans have become
very xenophobic when they visit the
hall of records you see galadriel make
a lot of references to elrond and elros
i already explained their backstory how he
basically chose to live a mortal life and founded
numenor in elrond chose to live life as an elf
the other funny thing too is that galadriel is way
way older than elrond elrond and his brother were
actually born on middle earth many years after the
elves sailed to middle earth in the wars with more
gothic started as i mentioned earlier they also
confirmed that the mark in addition to a couple
other things is also meant to be a map marker and
they explain how there was this contingency plan
that sauron developed in the case of morgoth's
defeat when she says the language of the plan is
the black speech it's basically the exact same
language that's written on the one ring of power
the main language they speak in mordor eventually
obviously they're still making mordor as we
speak slowly terraforming the southlands i think
the more interesting thing now to theorycraft
though in the creation of mordor what's going
to be happening during the end of the second age
the war the last alliance the war of the ring is
that it actually implies that hal brand or his son
theo like if theo really does wind up being his
son will be unsuccessful like galadriel is trying
to give him this motivational speech the same way
that elrond later in the timeline tries to give
to aragorn but because we know what happens later
in the timeline it kind of seems like hal bran's
story ends in a super big downer moment you guys
can let me know in the comments do you think that
he becomes the witch king of angmar or one of the
nazgul or do you think that it's theo that winds
up becoming the witch king or one of the nazgul
i am positive there's going to be a huge twist
with that storyline later we check back in with
the harvest when they say they've heard of beings
turned into stars they might actually be referring
to the silmarils because one of the summariles
basically turned into something that they call
the star of arendelle that becomes this star that
the elves eventually worship a lot of what happens
in the episode is setting up the idea that i
think nori will leave to go with this meteor
man possibly a wizard character to go find this
place where they're creating mordor the whole
idea is that the constellation that he created
in episode two was meant to be like a map marker
he's probably looking for the place where they're
creating mordor in the southlands when her mother
says the stars reached down and touched her that's
a reference more to meteor man literally being
like one of these fallen angel characters in the
tolkien lore like she kind of did physically get
touched by a star in a way then when muriel goes
to visit her father the previous king that got
deposed in the tower when she says the moment they
feared is here because galadriel has arrived the
thing they fear is probably the return of sauron
like they're probably worried more about that
and this is kind of a misdirect like she seemed
very standoffish with galadriel i think that's a
misdirect i think eventually she's gonna try and
help galadriel my big theory right now for meteor
man is that he's either one of the blue wizards
or he's like a brand new wizard that they just
created for the show i don't think that he's going
to be gandalf or like one of the pre-existing
major wizards from the third age i don't think
they want to break the timeline that much
then at the end of the episode they have that cool
elves versus orcs fight a lot of cool chain kata
they also show you that orcs are literally burned
by the sun and that's why they spend so much time
burrowing through the earth that's why they live
underground because they can't walk around during
daylight the work that they unleash on them is the
same type of larger wolves that were featured in
the hobbit movies and as they almost escape they
reveal the adar character the fallen elf played
by joseph molly like i said i think he's just an
underling of saurons and currently head of their
faction right now until sauron himself surfaces
and takes command which might not happen to like
the very end of the season or season two i don't
think it'll happen for a little while now i am
thinking that we won't actually see sauron himself
for a while but if you spotted any other easter
eggs or references in the episode that i didn't
talk about in the video just write them below in
the comments there's like a thousand things that
they reference from the lore here so you could
watch the episode like 10 times and still find
new little details my episode 4 video will post
next week after they release it in my house of
the dragon episode 4 video will post this sunday
disney plus day is also this weekend there's
a bunch of marvel trailers probably some star
wars trailers i'll do videos for all that
stuff as well so be sure to enable alerts
for my channel so you don't miss any of that
everyone click here for my full house of the
dragon episode 4 trailer video and click here for
my rings of power episode 1 and episode 2 video
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!